hey youtubers is Charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's Walking Dead Q&A there's a
lot of students talk about so we'll get
through questions first but I do have a
few announcements at the end of the
video there were also a few important
things that Scott Gimple and Greg
Nicotero confirmed after the episode
first the guy in the flashbacks was not
negan he was just a crazy tattoo man
that they let out number two they're
doing something super secret with Morgan
and number three there will be a new
villain that'll at least be as evil as
the governor it won't be a copy of the
governor it'll just be someone really
terrible and for those that don't know
there's a lot of stuff going on with the
Walking Dead spin-off show I've already
done a big video on it so I'll add a
link to that in the description if you
want to learn more about it careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
so here we go question number one dirt
buffin that is an awesome name do you
think the beth will reunite with the
group yes I definitely think she's not
gonna die
I believe we won't see her at least till
the third episode maybe the teaser at
the end episode two presumably there
will be some exposition explaining how
she got where she is and who those
people are I don't think they're gonna
do the exact same thing as they did with
terminus I did follow all the news from
when they were filming this season so I
don't wanna get crazy with spoilers but
I can definitely say that other place
won't be another version of terminus
they're not just gonna blow it up the
first time we see it
I think Beth's Ark is mostly gonna be a
continuation of what we saw when she was
off with Daryl like she's just slowly
growing up and getting used to being on
her own Emily Kinney is still a series
regular as far as I know so even though
she won't be with the survivors we'll
still see a lot of her just in separate
scenes question number two
Edward asks do you think that Morgan
will reunite with the group by the next
episode or are they gonna drag it out
yeah they're definitely gonna drag it
out Scott Gimple confirmed they're doing
something super secret with his
storyline so it will be really cool but
it's gonna be a separate thing he and
Kirkman have both said that they
incorporated a lot more elements from
the comics this year that doesn't mean
they're straight-up copying what happens
to Morgan in the comics but if you have
read them some people and some things
will seem a lot more familiar I feel
like it's just the two of them gently
suggesting that everyone start reading
the comics if they aren't already right
now I'm still behind I haven't read all
worried yet so do not feel bad if you
haven't read the calm
I think the Morgan stuff will be just
like Beth you know he'll be off in a
zone the difference is is we'll just see
way less of Morgan
they have tees that the group is gonna
head back to really big familiar
location which I think is Atlanta so
it's possible Morgan could also be
headed in that direction
because he obviously turned around he
was going to terminus and then turned
around I don't know that he's ever gonna
become a series regular but I do think
by season six he will have met Rick in
the group the actor says he loves coming
on the show so always keep coming back
question number three Jasmine asks do
you think that Gareth will die this
season or turn good and join the
survivors so the actor that plays Gareth
Andrew J West was promoted to series
regular after the finale last year so
he's definitely in most if not all the
episodes this season probably all of
them it doesn't necessarily mean he's
gonna turn good enjoying the survivors I
have seen a lot of theories that I
really like that he and whoever's left
from terminus will turn into the hunters
from the comics they were already
cannibals to begin with so they were
halfway there it just means it's
possible that Gareth and whoever's left
could be haunting Rick and the survivors
throughout the season question number
four Cass asks where did Rick and the
survivors go after they reunited so it
seems like they headed in the opposite
direction from terminus they have to run
into father Gabriel at some point
because we saw him in the teaser I don't
know where his church is on the map but
in the trailers we've seen in the
footage we've seen they're approaching
it at night so it's not gonna be like a
simple save Gabriel then go back to his
place and chill type thing there are a
lot of trailer scenes of them hanging
out inside the church so those might all
be from that second episode father
Gabriel in the comics is actually a
really interesting character so I'm
interested to see how much of that they
adapt for the TV show in case you don't
want to know anything about him just
turn the volume down till you see this
tag go away okay so right after the
apocalypse Gabriel hoarded supplies in
his church and refused to let people in
very ungodly thing to do for a priest he
was afraid of running low on food and
water so he carries around the guilt of
the people who died because of his
selfishness okay so suppose over if you
guys actually want to talk a lot more
about Gabriel in the comics just let me
know and I'll include him in my episode
2 video Seth Gilliam is an awesome actor
so I'm really looking forward to seeing
him on the show and it brings them one
step closer to hiring every single actor
that has ever
appeared on the wire they're actually
getting close they're getting close
number five Daniel asks will the show
makes sense if I just start watching now
in season five so it'll take you longer
to connect with the characters to
develop like that deep personal
connection to people but you still
should be able to follow even though
it's highly serialized they write
episodes knowing that people are
watching for the first time and people
may not have read the comics so they do
add bits of exposition and moments to
explain what's going on either way
welcome to the family it's gonna be
really fun show this year question
number six Shabab asks why would they
bring sandbag just to kill him off at
the beginning of the episode yeah so big
shout out for the penguin they said they
flew him out literally so he'd just
kneel there and they could slice his
throat it was like a one day thing Sam
was just the redshirt they used to crank
up the threat level him and the guy
right next to him they just wanted us to
feel as the audience like they were
actually gonna kill people in there
Robin Laura Taylor for those that don't
know is the penguin on Gotham that show
just got picked up for a full 22
episodes it airs Monday nights and I
actually do videos for it every week so
if you check back on my channel later
tonight I'll actually have an episode 3
video for that question number 7 horror
geek ass they're only about 5 characters
left from the original pilot episode how
long do you think they'll survive I
would not be surprised if they stayed on
indefinitely it seems like the show does
try to keep the biggest actors around as
long as possible
it's usually the guest stars that you
need to worry about and I know there
were all those playful links to negan in
a certain comic book moment but I think
the only time they kill off major
characters is when they get the sense
the group gets way too comfortable
the minute that everyone feels really
safe and happy that's when we need to
start worrying what might end up
happening now is a rift could develop
between Abraham's group and the
survivors over the Cure and that'll just
create internal tension here then
whoever else shows up will probably
provide the external tension like there
always has to be threats inside the
group and threats outside the group
question number 9
blacksmith rage asks do you think that
Michonne will get her katana back I
didn't see carol krabit but she does
have it in the trailers so I am a little
confused it seems like someone went back
and got it
I think they'll explain in the next
episode because she definitely has a
sword right here if you remember last
season there was this
with baby Judith where everyone thought
that she was left behind because she
couldn't see her on tyreese's back it
could be the same situation Carol could
have just picked it up and we just
didn't see question number 11 Raul asks
do you think the Carol's a version of
Andrea from the comics she's also a good
sharpshooter and a badass they do have a
lot of similar qualities but I think
they kind of split a lot of Andrea up
amongst the other characters I think
there's a lot of her story in Michonne
and Carol right now I don't know if
that'll continue to be the case but you
could draw some connections between
those three characters question number
12 purely awesome asks why do you think
they chose not to show Tyreese killing
the terminus guy and why didn't he want
Carol to go in the cabin so there is a
small chance that he did not kill that
guy and that's why he doesn't want Carol
to see I think Tyreese having a problem
killing people will work into the
Garrett's storyline and probably cause
some problems later on like you saw it
was really hard for him to kill that guy
and we'd never saw it actually go down
regardless of what happened I think
they'll definitely address it again if
you remember the Lizzie mica storyline
they offhandedly started that with the
rats in episode 1 hopefully this won't
snowball into a look at the flowers
Tyreese situation thank you so much
everyone for so many questions these are
always a ton of fun to do and
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner oliver yoshi you in the Amazon
giftcard the next round of the giveaway
will start next Sunday whenever I post
my episode 2 video for those asking it
is a new giveaway every week and I also
do giveaways in my Doctor Who and Game
of Thrones videos probably some other
random giveaways happening with DC and
Marvel stuff too
so the more different things you check
out the better your chances are for
catching all that stuff and for those
asking about Game of Thrones videos
specifically I'm probably gonna move
those to Friday's just because my Sunday
Monday is now are getting kind of log
jammed that's not meant to sound like a
sex thing either way
[ __ ] goes down with father Gabriel next
week I'll play up a bonus video to post
before the episode airs right now you
can click here to learn all about the
Walking Dead spin-off show it's actually
gonna be really cool Inc click here for
my episode 1 WTF video thank you so much
for watching so let's all high-five I'll
see you guys tonight forgot them
you